the management of cancer involves the
services of several disciplines
utilizing the judgment and skills of the
surgeon
the pathologist the internist
and the radiation therapist
at the very outset it is important to
determine which modality of treatment
or combination will most likely benefit
the patient
and whether treatment is to be given
with intent to cure
or for palliation
radiation doses and treatment schedules
vary greatly depending upon therapeutic
aims
and the radiation therapist like the
surgeon and chemotherapist
is guided by the classic dictum first
do no harm
the objective to deliver a cancer
recital dose to the tumor
with the least possible damage to the
surrounding tissues
in outlining a treatment plan the
therapist considers many factors
the general status of the patient the
type and location of the tumor
its volume its expected response to
radiation
these and other physical and biological
factors will govern the selection of the
appropriate type of radiation
isodose chart showing the penetration of
the beam for a given energy
will help verify the suitability of the
radiation
for the particular location of the tumor
radiation therapy uses a variety of
equipment providing a wide spectrum of
wavelengths and penetration
characteristics
this low voltage 100 kilovolt unit is
suitable for treating superficial thin
lesions such as this basal cell
carcinoma
the 100 kilovolt unit produces soft
x-rays of low penetration
which deposit most of their energy in
the first few centimeters of tissue
generators in the 250 to 300 kilovolt
range produce
x-rays of somewhat greater penetration
useful for treating superficial thick
lesions
as for example this tumor of the parotid
gland
megavolt million volt equipment produces
still harder more penetrating radiation
a two million volt machine such as this
resonant transformer
is suitable for treating deeper lesions
here used to irradiate para aortic lymph
node metastases
in a patient with a testicular carcinoma
six million volt x-rays are produced by
this linear accelerator
with a betatron 35 or even 45 million
electron volt x-rays can be obtained
the penetration achieved with these high
energies permits treatment at depths
beyond the effective reach of lower
energy beams
as seen in this comparison
as noted earlier the energy from a low
voltage 100 kev
unit is quickly absorbed and does not
penetrate much beyond the superficial
tissues
with approximately eight percent of the
maximum dose
measurable at a depth of 10 centimeters
approximately 35 percent of the maximum
dose reaches this level
with 250 kev radiation
the 2 million volt generator delivers
approximately 50 percent of its maximum
dose at this depth
the six million volt linear accelerator
delivers 70 percent
and the 35 mev betatron delivers a full
85 to 90 percent of its dose maximum
at 10 centimeters
icidose charts used by the therapist in
planning treatment
show the dose distribution in
percentages of the maximum dose
for a given energy at various depths
below the skin
surface
each chart identifies the modality the
source skin distance
and the field size
the penetration of these high energy
beams permits effective irradiation of
deep-seated tumors
in addition at higher energies
the edges of the beam are sharp because
these highly energetic x-rays are not
significantly scattered by the
irradiated tissues
either backward or laterally
as is the case with low energy radiation
where there is significant scatter
outside the field
the more sharply defined edges of the
high energy beam confine the radiation
more precisely to the treated area
another advantage of high energy
radiation is that the maximum dose is
not reached at the skin
surface but at varying depths beneath it
so that skin reactions are not a
limiting factor
high energy ionizing radiation in the
megavolt range can also be obtained with
relatively simple equipment
using radioactive isotopes such as
cobalt 60
the cobalt 60 unit emits gamma
radiations which are similar in
penetration to x-rays produced by a 3
million volt generator
gamma radiation from isotopes is
indistinguishable from electrically
produced x-rays of the same energy
of all high-energy installations in use
today
more than eighty percent are cobalt
sixty units
here used to treat the patient with
hodgkin's disease
the quantity of emitted radiation is
expressed in renkins
a unit of measure of ionization in air
however the amount of energy absorbed in
tissue is measured in rads
the unit of radiation absorb dose
rad equaling 100 ergs of energy absorbed
per gram of tissue
absorbed dose however varies with tissue
composition and radiation energy as
illustrated in this x-ray film
at low energies 250 kev or less
there is a significant difference in
absorption between soft tissue and bone
because of the greater absorption of
energy by the denser skeletal tissues
at higher energies this absorption
differential does not exist
and the amount of energy absorbed by
bone and soft tissue is about equal
this allows treatment to cancer acidal
doses in the vicinity of bone
without producing bone damage because of
increased absorption
this side by side comparison shows the
difference in absorption at low
and high energies
the effects of radiation are initiated
by the interaction of the x-rays or
gamma rays with the orbital electrons of
the tissue atoms
the displaced electrons and scattered
photons cause
increasingly large numbers of
ionizations as they penetrate the tissue
the released electrons act as chemically
reactive reducing substances
forming free radicals and producing
chemical damage
including damage to dna
damage to dna may be reparable or may
result in cell death
clinically observable as tumor shrinkage
the initial manifestation of cell death
often occurs at the time of mitosis
this cell which has previously been
irradiated is about to divide
at first it appears normal
however as cell division proceeds the
chromosomes tend to clump together
and a chromosome bridge can be seen to
connect the two potential daughter cells
this abortive division is one of a
number of manifestations of lethal cell
damage following irradiation
in general the sensitivity of a cell to
the effects of radiation seems largely
related to its mitotic activity
cells which are mitotically most active
are usually the most radio sensitive
illustrated here by this poorly
differentiated squamous cell carcinoma
of the nasal pharynx
among the most radio sensitive tumors
are the malignant lymphomas
and leukemias undifferentiated squamous
cell carcinomas
and germinal tumors such as seminomas
and dis germanomas
moderately radio sensitive are the
well-differentiated squamous cell
carcinomas of the skin and mucous
membranes
adenocarcinomas and some sarcomas
relatively radio resistant tumors
include osteogenic sarcomas
malignant melanomas and some gliomas
radiosensitivity of a tumor however is
not necessarily related to curability
since tumors with a high degree of radio
sensitivity
are often those which also show marked
anaplasia
aggressive growth and wide dissemination
in fact the chances for cure of a cancer
by irradiation depend
mainly on its location its size and
accessibility
its biological behavior and probably on
immunological factors
the general condition of the patient is
of considerable importance and can
significantly influence the patient's
tolerance to irradiation
cancer of the cervix is a classic
example in which radiation therapy is
given with the intent to cure
with irradiation as the principal
treatment modality
recent five-year survival rates free of
disease
were reported by a major institution as
follows
this patient was initially examined by
her referring gynecologist
who biopsied a lesion on the cervix
examination of the biopsy specimen
showed a moderately differentiated
squamous cell
carcinoma and she was referred to the
radiation therapist for consultation
the cystoscopic examination and
intravenous urogram were within normal
limits
blood count and chemistries were also
normal
vaginal examination revealed a
normal-sized slightly anti-flexed uterus
with a tumor involving the external
cervical ass
and extending into the left fornix
on rectovaginal examination the lesion
is felt to involve the medial aspect of
the left parametrium
without reaching the pelvic wall
classifying this as a stage
2b tumor
in order to plan the treatment certain
measurements are needed
the anterior posterior diameter is
measured
and recorded on plotting paper
the contour of the pelvis is then
obtained with lead tape
and is also traced
and superimposed on the appropriate
icidose chart
treatment will be given through two
opposed fields
the dose contribution of the anterior
field is plotted
and then that of the posterior
this will result in a relatively
homogeneous dose distribution
and the volume to be treated avoiding
regions of overdoses or
under dosage compounding of the doses
contributed by each field
results in these summation curves
the limits of the treatment field are
outlined on the skin
and entered in the patient's treatment
chart
she will receive daily treatments of 200
rads through both the anterior and
posterior fields
until a tumor dose of about four
thousand rads has been reached
well within the tolerance of the normal
pelvic tissue
fractionating the total dose into small
increments over a protracted period
results in greater dose tolerance and
favors recovery of the non-cancerous
tissues
the field size is optically simulated
using a beam collimator which is
adjusted to conform with a treatment
field
and the treatment is started
if there are no interruptions in the
treatment schedule the goal of four
thousand rads will be attained in
approximately four weeks
on the last day of cobalt therapy the
left parametrium has returned to almost
normal consistency
and the lesion at the cervical ass is
now visible as a small
whitish area of necrotic tumor tissue
treatment will be completed with
intravaginal and intrauterine
radium therapy this permits delivery of
a very high dose to the central most
resistant part of the lesion
and simultaneously increases the dose to
the lateral pelvic tissues
a tumor dose of the level attained by
this method cannot be reached
by external radiation alone
after cervical dilatation a tandem is
inserted into the uterine canal
followed by copa stats placed into the
lateral fornices
the position of the radium containing
applicators is verified radiographically
these films permit calculation of the
exact dose delivered to the tumor
and adjacent structures
examination after completion of the full
course of treatment
shows the healed cervix
radiation therapy with the goal of
palliation is exemplified in this
patient with a six-month history of
difficulty in
swallowing solid foods and recent weight
loss
the esophagram demonstrated amid
thoracic obstructive lesion
which on biopsy proved to be a squamous
cell carcinoma
treatment will be given by rotating beam
technique
on a contour of the patient's chest
radii
are drawn from the axis of rotation
to the skin surface the axis is located
at the exact
center of the tumor
the radii will be used in the
computation of the summation curves
these indicate a maximum dose region
surrounding the tumor
and a much lower dose to the adjacent
organs
the chances for cure in carcinoma of the
esophagus are statistically very small
since metastases are frequently present
when the cancer is diagnosed
nevertheless one can usually obtain
significant palliation with radiation
therapy
this split screen comparison shows the
grossly normal appearance of the
esophagus approximately one month after
the end of treatment
in addition to its use as a primary
modality of treatment
radiation therapy can be effective in
combination with other types of therapy
for example children with wilms tumor
show a higher survival rate when
radiation therapy is used
in addition to surgery and chemotherapy
in this post-operative patient
irradiation may limit metastatic spread
by destroying any cancer cells which may
have been left behind in the renal bed
in some cases of this disease
pre-operative irradiation is given
in an effort to destroy tumor cells
which might be disseminated at
nephrectomy
in recent years the combination of
surgery radiation and chemotherapy
has resulted in a dramatic increase in
survival rates in wilms tumor
radiation therapy also has a major role
in the treatment of many other types of
cancer
in a patient with carcinoma of the
larynx with the lesion limited to one or
both cords and no fixation
radiation therapy can offer a cure and
has the advantage of preserving the
voice
this patient received a course of cobalt
sixty therapy over a period of forty
three days
one month after completion of treatment
laryngoscopy
showed no evidence of residual tumor
as with all patients treated by
irradiation this man is now seen
regularly for follow-up examination
mr benkowski you feel well yes sir
how long has it been now about five
years since yes five years old
and your voice stays strong oh yeah
strong enough
all the time and how about the
swallowing swallowing is okay
you want to take your dentures out and
put them into this
i can do that
yes now open your mouth up wide
now stick your tongue out let me see it
all right now
say e
say e again
very good that's fine whether used with
the intent to cure
or with the intent to palliate alone
or in combination with other treatment
modalities
radiation therapy has a major role in
the management of cancer
in fact at some time in the course of
treatment
at least fifty percent of patients with
cancer can benefit from radiation
therapy
about half of these treated for cure
and half for palliation
you